it's really great to be joined today by
Peter Joseph the founder of the
zeitgeist movement and author of the new
book which I have here the new new human
rights movement Peter it's so great to
talk to you you know I really enjoyed
going through most of the book over the
last week or ten days or so and I think
to get our audience into what you're
tackling in this particular book I'm
sort of left with the idea of looking at
individual problems from a structuralist
perspective or a broader perspective
than we otherwise might I mean is that a
sort of good way to assess the general
idea of this book yes that's a pretty
good encapsulation and when you started
writing this book or I guess tell me how
you approach the problem was it that of
course in your in your time researching
individual topics you decided hey
there's a broader issue or a broader
perspective we can look at that it come
in the opposite direction did you enter
with one particular issue like for
example poverty or hunger both of which
you address in the book I would say the
motivation to approach it this way is
taking a good hard look at what we've
done as activists throughout time the
activist community tends to be far more
localized and their views they separate
themselves into different schools so to
speak of the ecological activists the
social activists and so on
and after spending a lot of years as an
activist myself looking at the world's
problems I realized that there was a
strong lapse of any kind of social
psychology anything that related to
sociology itself denying effectively the
long-standing social science the
biological science the psychological
science sociological science the
ecological influences and that synergy
that really defines us as human beings
and ultimately defines the state of the
world so I'm trying to take a social
science perspective with this book and I
think if people understand it and that's
why it's called the new human rights
movement obviously this subject could
given the context of structuralism as I
call it you could apply to a lot of
different things but I want to hone in
on activism for the 21st century
so that's the motivation to get people
on board with more of a social
psychology perspective of what needs to
happen to understand yourself
the predicament of the world and how to
change it maybe to give our audience an
example of one issue that you tackle in
the book we could talk a little bit
about poverty and you know I think we we
all can probably imagine the people we
know who approach poverty from you know
this is sort of the way things are
despite our system poverty is an
inevitability it's always there it's
always going to be there and you take a
different approach which is poverty is
an optional and also direct result of
the systems that that we've chosen so
can we start maybe with the conversation
around poverty and how you approach it
yeah
yes it's disheartening to see how passes
people have become about both domestic
and international poverty poverty is in
the words of Gandhi the worst form of
violence stem eclis speaking it leads to
so many different detrimental outcomes
whether you're dealing with mental
health whether you're dealing with
interpersonal relationships of course
whether you're dealing with physical
health and if you look closely poverty
and it's and it's encapsulating the
system overarching system reference that
you call socio-economic inequality which
is what I address throughout the book a
lot poverty is is an externality of our
system an externality of market
capitalism some externality of the
economy and it within this uh within
that particular context it's a great
starting point because I think everyone
has experienced poverty on some basic
level whether vicariously watching the
the global south and the the complete
destitution that still exists there
today as a issue of post colonialism
which is something to point out as well
I mean I don't want to get too spirally
here but I think it's important to point
out that people have this great
mythology about where poverty came from
and people say well we've just left
people behind in capitalism and so on
the people in the global South in Africa
Latin America Asia and so on that are
still invested to third world poverty
are not there because they've been left
behind they're there because over the
course of time they've effectively been
robbed
and that's something that isn't given
enough gravity of course excuse me in
the intellectual circles as to why these
things exist which makes you kind of
upset when you hear people talk about
how we
advanced poverty on this planet without
talking about the fact that the reason
poverty exists is because of the social
systems incentives at the same time over
the long term but to be more specific to
your question poverty is both a a cause
and an effect in terms of Epidemiology
in social science research people refer
to poverty as a root of something for
example families in poverty are known to
create children that have lower IQs the
brain function doesn't develop as well
as reductions in the amygdala and
hippocampus literally your brain
creating brain damage through the
synergy of poverty and deprivation
that's just one example but it's also
known as a as an effect too and that's
why it's addressed in the book as such I
refer to it as a negative externality
for those familiar with familiar with
economics an externality is something
that happens outside of the purview the
reference point of what economics
recognizes so pollution is a negative
externality for example as is poverty
and that's a pretty radical thing for me
to say because as you've pointed out
most people have not perceived it that
way but when you look at the amount of
wealth on this planet in material terms
I'm not just talking about money but
even if you look at the money it's
pretty staggering you know we all know
about the inequality statistic some will
go into that poverty could easily be
resolved both through financial means
and through efficient use of resources
with modern methods but we don't do it
because of the way the economic
structure is organized its incentives
its procedural dynamics you could say
and that is of course a big subject in
the book and I really hope people will
begin to understand more so that poverty
is really just a form of violence coming
down from our social system doesn't need
to exist and we should work to change it
and Peter piece some people will hear
what we've talked about so far and
they'll say listen you're you're
criticizing the capitalist system and
you know some people are poor in
capitalism but if you're alluding to
communism
everybody's poor in communism how does
someone like you who has such a nuanced
and detailed knowledge of these issues
start to break through those sort of
knee-jerk reactions from some who
who would no doubt have that reaction
when hearing what you've outlined so far
what's the best path into a productive
conversation with someone who reacts
that way I think the first step is to
start to expose the mythology the
Western world has just has ascribed to
when it comes to historical communism
historical communism is practiced in the
Soviet Union was a particular niche a
particular kind of central planning a
particular kind of authoritarianism and
when people say this they automatically
create a false duality between
capitalism and then this other supposed
a ideal of what communism is or was or
was supposed to be and what it is or was
or was supposed to be in terms of
communism or socialism or Marxism any of
those terms that people want to throw
out it's it's extremely
counterproductive because there's very
little critical analysis or historical
understanding of what actually happened
with those social systems or social
approaches not to mention the grand
ambiguity I mean they even talk about
what socialism means today is to define
it about you know ten dozen different
ways as I think you know so I step back
from that and I try to take a train of
thought perspective as opposed to a
polarized one just because something
isn't market capitalism doesn't
necessarily mean it's communism so you
start from that position and then you
start to outline what it is in society
that's actually created the advancement
and I think I wouldn't say things like
economic growth because that's a
contrivance of market capitalism but
what has actually improved people's
lives what are the mechanisms that have
led to higher standards of living to
reduced child mortality to to the
current alleviation of poverty that's
been slowly slowly getting a little bit
better over the course the past 6070
years and the answer to that is the
application of design efficiency and
technology and as I get to the end of
this book I hone in on those specific
points that have actually underscored
the benefit of our economic efficiency
benefited of us as in our public health
and so on and I isolate those from the
market and I want to encourage people to
develop a new system that harnesses
those issues harnesses the amazing
efficient
we've achieved that achieve this human
being as intelligent thinkers as opposed
to this archaic system that is lost and
what's called the Malthusian period it's
lost in this Malthusian Machiavelli in
highly scarcity-driven world so I
apologize I've deviated a bit from your
question when people approach me with
the communists duality I pretty much
just have to stop them and begin a long
explanation that what they're
referencing is a false duality to begin
with and that if you really want to get
down to it here are the here's the train
of thought here are the attributes that
define our society it made it better why
can't we simply amplify these attributes
without any you use ideological stigma
as an interference and sadly enough
stigmas and labels and interference has
been a great way to to dismiss a lot of
these ideas over time so it's
unfortunately a current that we have to
walk against still in the 21st century
let's pause there with Peter Joseph
founder of the zeitgeist movement author
of the new book the new human rights
movement and we'll pick it up in part
two with the concept of scarcity which
you've spoken about a lot and is
interesting to me so we'll follow up
there
we're continuing our conversation today
with Peter Joseph founder of the
zeitgeist movement also author of the
new book the new human rights movement
we started getting into Peter this
concept of scarcity and I want to talk
about that sort of in the context of
market capitalism and in many more
microwaves you point out in the book for
example with food production and hunger
that the concept of scarcity and lack of
resources to meet the needs is
essentially a contrived result of how
we've decided to allocate resources and
you point out in great detail in the
appendix to the book how not only food
production and hunger could be solved
with current resources and technology
but so could clean water and energy
let's maybe start and focus on food
production and hunger would you call
this a decision that has been made as
effectively by global society not to
solve the problem of hunger well that
would inch into kind of a conspiratorial
view which I don't subscribe to with
with any of this what I think it is it's
a cultural unfolding that goes back that
goes back hundreds of years to before
the the 18th century late eighteenth
century and the start of the Industrial
Revolution what some people call the
great divergence scarcity has been with
society in a very visceral visceral way
since the Neolithic Revolution 12,000
years ago when we we emerge from
hunter-gatherer tribes that had a fairly
abundant amount of resources and a
completely different type of lifestyle
and then once settled agrarian society
happened it's set a kind of geographical
determinism so to speak something other
theorist called cultural anthropology if
anyone wants to look that up it's very
fascinating and it set the framework for
what we see as the market economy today
property of capital the means production
aid labor specialization jobs you need
for regulation government protection law
and so many other attributes like that
which codified the system we have at the
moment and within that is the
fundamental foundation of the assumption
of universal scarcity and it's become a
political political term the
because of if you believe in anything
other than a scarcity worldview then
suddenly you can't justify the ramp into
competition that we see suddenly you
can't justify eight people having more
wealth than the bottom 50% of the world
suddenly you can't justify all of this
imbalance and that's why scarcity has to
be re-evaluated in a very very serious
way and going to the food part we throw
away half of our food right now on this
planet roughly almost ever have the food
produced in this planet with all the
energy and hydrocarbons gets trashed
because of inefficiency in the pipeline
and a general or belligerence of Western
culture at the same time in our
gratuitous materialism our lack of
consideration of what's really happening
in the world that's an unfortunate
phenomenon culturally in Western
societies were blocked off anyway so you
have that already that we had the
potential to feed the entire world we
produce enough calories to feed the
world more or less two times over and
then you have the Applied Technology
that isn't being utilized systems based
technology the incredible efficiency
possibility is a vertical farm systems
of engineered a permaculture of all
sorts of advanced means that would for
example if you localized food production
say I'm in Los Angeles and we could
localize all of our produce if we wanted
to eliminating the fact that the average
American meal travels about 1500 miles
before it goes to your plate think about
that because of this this hard work of
globalization which is about
exploitative you know labor and far
distant lands along with resources so we
can do it with what we have today and if
you apply an advanced technology that we
have under our belt but is not being
funded or subsidized or invested into
the degrees that are required we could
easily create a total food abundance on
this planet I can continue with the
other well I was going to say to stick
with this example just to sort of see it
through it so people can understand sort
of your thought process with something
like this what you're saying will make a
lot of sense to most people who are
listening to or watching this interview
and it will also seem like something
that we should be taking more seriously
as a society as a human race but what's
the first step in starting to unwind the
system we have and we can we can do it
through this issue of hunger just
because we've been talking about
uh how do you start like what step one
and we talk a lot you know I'm reminded
of campaign finance reform everybody
talks about campaign finance reform
you've got to fix how we finance
elections here's ten different ways that
it could be done great our decision
makers are in because of the system that
got them there why would they change the
system that got them there we're already
at a sort of impasse so how do you start
working against such an establishment
incumbent system to make positive change
well at the core you need a galvanized
community that wants it let's point that
out first of all and without the
educational work that needs to be done
such as such as why the book was written
to see the potentials you can't get very
far people still believe in general
scarcity as a as a as the politicized
symbology it is that justifies the
unequal world that we have and we're not
going to get very far but in terms of
technicals as I mentioned briefly and
what I said prior localization of food a
couple with advanced automation
technology we already have we could
easily create local the amount of food
that's required without the need for
transport I'm big on that I think well I
always maintain a global consciousness
in terms of recognizing the world as one
systemic whole but at the same time
there are good reasons to localize and
to make things regionally specific
namely for the saving of efficiency
transport efficiency energy efficiency
and of course distribution efficiency so
if it was me and I was a position of
policy what I would do is create large
and automated agricultural systems
specifically vertical farms or other
potentials but we'll just go with that
one those have tremendous efficiency
potentials because they can be building
industrial urban areas and they use very
little water resources and nutrients to
produce very high quality produce and
you put those along the coastlines of
Los Angeles wherever you are you can put
them anywhere ultimately and irrigate to
them and then you you basically do not
import anything anymore you make it a
basic localized mandate to create local
food and if you do that you're going to
solve the poverty problem by extension
then eventually you make it free once
the automated systems are in place you
quote socialize it I used that almost
tongue-in-cheek
but in the most traditional sense today
the use of social return social is a
means to make publicly available without
the need for exchange and if you had a
system doing that with minor subsidy
ssin along with the technical efficiency
that would maximize the efficiency
output along with reducing the amount of
labour required you could do it and you
would end poverty region by region
through that approach whether we're
talking about the poverty or hunger
example or more broadly because you
talked about so much in the book I mean
our criminal justice system
incarceration is an other area that you
write about significantly are most
people sort of thinking to micro even
about solutions I mean for example
universal basic income this is something
that you know economist Richard Wolfe
for example talks about as it's
something that would make sense within
the current system but it's not going to
change the system we have to one that
makes more sense how do you balance
micro approaches to fixing symptoms of
our current system versus activism
towards changing the system more broadly
balance is an interesting word I'd say
it's more of a progressive pattern that
pushes towards larger system changes
through more micro steps so universal
basic income is a step towards the
acknowledgement at a minimum that the
system we have is inefficient in its
distribution I mean that something that
needs to be just blatantly plastered
everywhere the reason we have inequality
is because the system is simply
inefficient and it stands in the face of
all those people to say well markets are
the most efficient system we've ever had
actually you couldn't possibly come up
with a more wasteful and inefficient
system than what we have today
so universal basic income coupled with
creating industries that become quote
socialized once again through advanced
technological means are two steps that
can lead us to transforming this society
in an incremental way I want to point
out since you brought up universal basic
income is I know a lot of people that
are big into this that's been on my mind
there's one big flaw with universal
basic income and this kind of insistent
solution and that comes down to what's
been termed by other historians as sort
of capitalist contradictions what's
happened since since the 1970s
specifically is the credit expansion in
the West has been outrageous you know
it's because there's so much debt
produced in the system but people can't
keep up wages have stagnated so in order
to keep money moving and this kind of
cyclical consumption economy that we
have you have to have give people money
and that what has been done with that is
through credit expansion you know 43% of
the average of skewb 43 percent of the
American population spends more than
they actually take in every single year
and it's not just because they're
flagrantly living beyond their means
they have to keep up they keep up with a
system that's effectively moving against
and something in the book I call
structural classism or structural
bigotry in effect so my point being is
that when you provide people with
universal basic income what you're
really doing is satisfying a built-in
inefficiency of capitalism which will
actually placate the capitalist system
if you don't have a larger view and I
hope people understand what I mean by
that because you're giving people money
they can spend back into the system
which ultimately through the magic of
structural classes and will trickle
right back up to the upper 1% anyway
well that's our sort of inherent sort of
uh impossibility of the system we have
and when you look at credit you would
only loan someone money if you believe
that in the future things are going to
be better for them such that they could
pay that back with interest so on and so
forth if you have a planet of limited
resources and size and some at least at
this point hypothetical maximum
population carrying capacity at some
point that system is going to fail you
isn't it well absolutely I mean if
you're speaking about credit as a
general phenomenon keep in mind we
produce more interest in this system
than money so the debt cost the interest
that's created is exceeds the money
supply of our entire planet which is
basically a recipe for bankruptcies and
failures and more oppression of
lower-class there's about two hundred
trillion dollars right now an
outstanding money excuse me an
outstanding debt on this planet 200
trillion and there's only about 81
trillion in actual currency actual money
so that that disparity effectively
translates into more repossessed houses
more empowerment of the financial
services sector and the
banking system they're the ones that
take that physical property hence the 1%
and the elitism that we see today and so
on and so forth so no it's not
sustainable it's only sustainable from
the standpoint of the acceptance of
social failure acceptance of social
inequality acceptance of social
oppression and suffering and sadly
enough people today have been so
indoctrinated into that reality they
can't see beyond it what I mean no doubt
about it and now thinking ahead I mean
it's such a 30,000 foot problem that I
think it's difficult for a lot of people
to even conceive of that well 200
trillion in debt 80 trillion in money
what eventually happens well you have
the boom and bust cycle as it's called
which is really driven less by tangible
innovation and so on as is pitched in
traditional economic workbooks and more
by just the influx and outflux of money
so you have credit periods of monetary
expansion you know whether it's basic
you know interest rates being raised
excuse me being lowered that creates
monetary expansion or when there's
crises they do QE and so on so you have
that period of expansion that invests
that creates more money in a circulation
that goes into the production of goods
and to the higher at people in labor and
any build effectively more debts because
all money is created out of debt be
aware that that's one of the central
problems underlying the market system so
all money is created out of debt with
interest charged upon it and you produce
to phenomenon you produce too much debt
you get debt saturation whether it's
domestically or internationally and then
you get inflation so when debt and
inflation becomes too high in the
boom-bust cycle that's when they
contract interest rates and that's when
you start to see the real structural
classes and kick in and that's what a
failure happens again we accept this
failure and though that's just the way
it is you as you know yeah it's really
stunning because the amount of suffering
that happens on that downturn is truly
staggering during the during the 2008
Great Recession there were 500,000
deaths during that block of time due to
a lack of medical treatment correlated
to the Great Recession for people that
had cancer there also about 46,000
suicides across the United States and
about 63 other nations that correlated
to it as well so this is a caustic
deadly phenomenon and people don't
perceive that structural violence
because they're detached
you know I mean they don't they said
everyone everyone thinks of violence is
you put a gun to somebody's head there's
a whole painful level of violence that
happens from a structural imposition
something Johan galtung called as I said
structural violence
he's another individual of the Gandhi
Institute I think people should look
into you and if people really realize
the violence that is happening through
things like the boom and bust cycle
through this debt system through just
the inequality gaming patterns that
happen with capitalism and the fact that
if you have enough money and wealth you
will continue to get more money in
wealth and power
so the social mobility has always been
in question it's much worse today than
it ever was and so on I think if you
know I often say I fear for the day I
both fear and long for the day David
where the general population realizes
the violence that's happening against
them because once they perceive that
it's not going to be pretty the book is
the new human rights movement we've been
speaking with the book's author Peter
Joseph also founder of the zeitgeist
movement Peter thanks so much for being
on have been looking forward to this
absolutely David I really appreciate
appreciate your time I think thank you
for the great show I always enjoy
listening to you thank you